Encuentra la pendiente de la línea que pasa
por los puntos 4, 2, y -3, 16.
Como un pequeño recordatorio, la pendiente
está definida como el alza entre el avance,
o dicho de otro modo, el alza es simplemente
el cambio en "y" y el avance es simplemente
el cambio en "x", este triangulito es una
delta mayúscula y significa "cambio en".
Así que esto es cambio en "y" entre cambio en "x".
Esta fórmula a veces aparece también como
"m" que significa pendiente,
así que esta es la pendiente, que es igual a... y vamos
a escribir lo mismo, el cambio en "y" es "y2"
menos "y1" entre "x2" menos "x1", que es el
cambio en "x".
Esto puede ser un poco confuso pero solo hay
que recordar que significa,
toma la coordenada "y" de tu segundo punto y réstale la coordenada "y" del primer punto
y eso te da el cambio en "y" y luego toma la coordenada "x" del segundo punto
y réstale la coordenada "x" del primer punto y eso te da el cambio en "x".
En realidad todas estas fórmulas dicen lo
mismo, pero bueno, vamos a calcular la pendiente
de la recta que pasa por esos dos puntos.
Así que empezamos... o de hecho podríamos
empezar en 4, 2 y terminar en -3, 16
ó empezar en -3, 16 y terminar en 4, 2.
Vamos a hacerlo de los dos modos, primero
vamos a considerar el caso en el que empezamos
en 4, 2 y vamos a tomar el punto de término,
el punto terminal como -3, 16.
Entonces, ¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "x"?
y ¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "y"?
A ver, nuestro cambio en "x" para empezar,
empecé en 4 y bajé a -3,
así que ¿cuánto cambie en la coordenada "x"?
Pues tuve que retroceder 7 espacios, tengo
que irme en reversa 7 lugares,
así que el cambio en "x" es de -7, pues retrocedí o
mejor escribámoslo así.
El cambio en "x" es igual a -3 menos 4 y esto es -7
y esto significa que empecé en 4 y retrocedí hasta -3, así que el cambio en "x" es de -7.
En realidad, esto está usando la fórmula
que tenemos por acá, nuestro cambio en "x"
es "x2", que es -3 menos "x1" que es 4, pero
bueno, vamos a hacer nuestro cambio en "y".
Nuestro cambio en "y" empiezo en 2 y termino en 16,
así que en realidad subí 14 unidades
o dicho de otro modo...
Si empecé en 2 y subí hasta 16, entonces
subí 16 menos 2, 14 unidades.
Entonces ahora bien, ¿cuál es la pendiente?
Pues la pendiente es el cambio en "y" entre
el cambio en "x",
pero esto simplemente es 14 que es el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x", que es -7.
Así que bueno, simplificando esta fracción,
obtenemos -2.
Ese es el valor de nuestra pendiente, -2.
ahora vamos a ver que en realidad pude haber
comenzado con el punto -3, 16 y terminar en
el 4, 2 y lo que hubiera pasado es que los
signos se hubieran intercambiado pero hubiéramos
obtenido el mismo valor para la pendiente.
Muy bien, así que pensemos ahora que
empezamos en el -3, 16.
Y pensemos que terminamos en el 4, 2.
Ahora, en esta situación
¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "x"?
Pues empecé en -3 y terminé en 4, así
que avancé, me fui a la derecha por 7 unidades,
así que sería 4 menos -3 que sería 7.
Y ahora, ¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "y"?
Pues ahora empecé en 16, empecé en 16 y
terminé en 2, así que en realidad bajé
14 unidades, así que el cambio sería negativo
o dicho de otro modo "y2" menos "y1" sería
2 menos 16, que es -14 y la pendiente sería
-14 que es el alza entre el avance que es de 7.
Así que noten como solo se intercambiaron los signos.
Y de nuevo, la pendiente vale -2.
Bien, pues ahora vamos a hacer una gráfica
para ver que significa geométricamente que
tengamos este valor de pendiente negativo,
así que aquí tengo mi eje "x" y acá tengo mi eje "y".
Primero vamos a colocar en la gráfica los
puntos -3, 16 y 4, 2
y después vamos a unirlos con la línea recta.
Tengo 1, 2, 3, 4...
4,...1, 2... así que aquí tengo el punto 4, 2
y luego tengo -3, 16,
así que tengo 3 unidades a la izquierda
y luego subo 16...
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 , 11, 12 ,13 ,14, 15, 16...
-3, 16, aquí está... -3, 16.
Y la línea que pasa entre estos 2 puntos...
la voy a tratar de dibujar, a ver...
va por ahí... así que más o menos es así la línea y obviamente continúa en ambas direcciones.
Ahora, noten, como la pendiente es negativa,
mientras la "x" crece,
la "y" se hace más pequeña, así que va de la izquierda superior, a la derecha inferior.
Y esto es lo que significa una pendiente negativa.
Ahora, para visualizar como cambiaron las
coordenadas, si empecé en 4 y terminé en -3...
si empiezo en 4, 2 y termino en -3,16
entonces empiezo aquí y termino allá,
mi cambio en "x" significa retroceder 7 unidades.
Mi avance no es un avance, sino un retroceso
de 7 unidades, por eso el -7
y luego subo en la dirección "y" durante 14 unidades y
esto si es positivo porque estoy subiendo
y obtuvimos la pendiente -2.
Ahora, si hubiera empezado acá y terminado
allá, si empiezo en -3, 16 y termino en 4, 2
entonces primero sí avanzo en dirección
"x"durante 7 unidades
y luego bajo en la dirección "y", bajo 14 unidades, pero como estoy bajando son -14,
pero de nuevo obtengo la pendiente -2.